hamid était tombé dans le banditisme à
14 ans ouais qu'est ce que tu as fait
ben c'est l'escaladé
voilà moi j'habitais une tour à l'époque
il y avait la cour des miracles
il ya longtemps nous c'était la tour des
miracles il y avait les vols et
cambriolages l'alcool la drogue la
troupe qu'on a baigné là dedans pour
nous c'était on pensait donc à ça donc
c'est l escalade les vols à l'étalagé
volant filouterie voit la filouterie ses
rentrées dans les moyennes surfaces sans
âme sans violence on est dans les
bureaux on chercher la clé du coffre
entre les gens faisaient leurs courses
non annualisé puis 10 à 14 ans on était
bonne élève chance débrouillez bien et
moi j'ai décidé de me débrouiller
bah ouais il nous parlait de notre
avenir mais nous l'avenir c'était
aujourd'hui demain savoir comment manger
comment s'habiller c'était ça n'a donc
nous nous parlait de plus tard de
travailler quand on aura 18 enfin nous
c'était là il fallait faire voilà
c'était alors vous avez fait quel type
de délit au début bah comme j'ai dit vol
à l'étalagé
on commence par le vol à l'étalagé un
classique pour manger pour s'habiller et
tous ensuite bas nous on était consul à
la fête tout à fait la tentative de
braquage à la société générale
il ya une étape quand même pas quand
même on fait on passe pas d'une pige de
certaines pistes noires exactement
exactement donc voilà donc les volants
filouterie c'est à dire la journée on
rentrait dans les magasins partout où
vous allez on chercher la clé du kop
dans les bureaux en bureaux et ont prôné
ce qu'elle le contenu du coffre sans
arme et sans violence
ensuite on les enfants n'écoutent et
surtout pas c'est non mais attention
parce qu'on va pas faire l'apologie du
bol ou du délit
ça les vois pas ce que vous allez voir
ce qu'a fait david après et justement
c'est justement pour ça qu'on l'a invité
ce soir parce que c'est voilà c'est pas
parce qu'ils racontent comics et bien on
y va exactement se rend compte qu'il a
prévu pour contacter éric il a fait
exactement
donc voilà l'escaladent ensuite on je me
suis très vite
spécialisé dans la neutralisation des
systèmes d'alarmé avec mes amis ont
cambriolé les banques la nuit sans armes
sans violence on rentrait ont découpé
les coffres forts au chalumeau des
coupeurs et toiles anciennes et puis
voilà on en a fait on n'a plus à l'achat
du mot du cou et des rampes
c'était le chalumeau dès que c'était à
l'ancienne quoi la bure un marteau
chalut et un vrai travail de nuit
en fait été tes voisins il était
persuadé que c'était boulanger quand la
nuit thuram n'est pas du temps à quoi
non mais même en plus c'est une une
belle bouteille parce que des fois les
premiers on emmenait les cov carrément
on les ans mais on les emmène en lozère
dans les garages des du quartier ont
découpé les coffres forts d'un gain et
après on a carrément amené le matos sur
place dans les grandes surfaces dans les
dents les banques et tous et ont découpé
les coffres forts et nous on pensait
donc à ça c'était notre vie quoi c'était
on avait gagné et c'était si tu allais
faire carrière
ouais pour moi pour moi c'était j'ai
appris tout gamin j'étais ont été
léguées laroque du quartier à faire que
ce à quoi s'est alors tu avec ta creusé
ensuite un tunnel pour rejoindre les
coffres de la société générale
oui voilà ça c'est là que tu t'es fait
continent et aux mille et une raisons
c'est parce que on est et ricard dans le
centre-ville à chaque fois qu'on se
faisait contrôler on était tellement
connue et à un moment j'ai dit les gars
on va passer en dessous ce dans les
égouts c'est comme les rues de il ya les
plaques de les mêmes bruits c'est pareil
sauf que des fois faut être en bateau
parce que c'est y aller il ya des egos
et les égouts vous avez été en bateau
mais on était donc dans les égoûts on à
visiter les égouts ont visité et là on a
vu une bouche d'égout qui étaient
proches de la banque
et donc dans la tête on sait ni ben
voilà on va creuser un tunnel et on
avait vu en plus que la salle des
coffres savoir on avait fait tout blanc
fin voilà et donc pendant quatre mois on
a creusé le tunnel pendant quatre mois
et à cause d'une petite erreur de notre
part
voilà que pendant quatre mois tu aurais
mieux fait de travailler quoi bein c'est
ce que je dis on dit dans les quartiers
que c'est des chômeurs des fois rien des
bois rien ou quoi mais non quand on
bosse on bosse alors et on à la
spaggiari quoi la spaggiari nous ont
comparé ce pack est arrivé c'est donc tu
t'es fait tu t'es fait coincer je me
suis fait coincer inventé vous êtes dans
le tunnel
alors non moi la sortie du tunnel il m'a
sorti à la sortie du tien je me fais
coincé avec un ami tous les autres ont
réussi à se barrer est arrivé au
commissariat garde à vue j'étais connu
comme le loup blanc et il me transfert
d'un commissariat un autre pour le pour
m'interroger à la pop à la pj et là dans
la voiture une comparer justement
spaggiari et le policier qui était à
côté de moi et me diras tu sais que tu
es nouveau spaggiari quand ça imite a
plus qu'à faire comme spaggiari l'ami
quatre mois pour s'évader
cinq minutes plus tard j'étais évadé
alors conduire à nous raconter après
c'est vrai parce que vous êtes arrêtés
menottés dans un camion de police
et qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce camion
de police et bien moi depuis tout gamin
j'avais une façon particulière de me
faire claquer les menottes jusque là
caméra et je jeu plié bien mon pouce a
fait que si je les claques et ici par
exemple toi et que tu tombes dont
ton point tu gagnes un jeu et donc
j'avais juste à péter mon pouce comme ça
et là je pouvais tirer la salle où
j'étais attaché comme ça il délirait sur
moi oui rigoler gervasi rigole on va
dans cinq minutes a pas d'un client mais
en fait moi même et donc là j'avais tiré
ma menottes et une comparé à spaggiari
mais réellement il était là tu sais que
tu ne sais pas si un nouveau spaggiari
de comment tout a toujours fait des
trucs sans violence toujours sans
violence j'ai voyagé pour moi voilà
fallait faire marcher sa tête et puis on
est donc là tu t'en l'est et menottes
donc non je les en effet tout de suite
ils me sortent du véhicule et me disent
par contre si on a un cas baiser
spaggiari gilbert avons essayé qu'à
baiser spaggiari
on peut pas te le dire il m'a dites le
moi il est mort spaggiari non peux pas
te le dire ils me font avancer comme ça
je dis mais dites le moi il est mort et
avant même que je pose mon pied sur la
première marche de la préfecture dit
voulais vraiment pas me dire qu'il a
baisé spaggiari non dérapante 10
rapports volte-face je suis parti en
courant
ils m'ont coursé là il y en a une cour
et derrière il arrête toi arrête arrête
toi je t'en supplie que je n'avais pas
faire demi-tour rigoler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
enfin le faire tout ça tout ce qui c'est
vrai christine absolument d'accord parce
que là on en rigole mais parce que vous
allez voir qu'après david il est rentré
dans si je peux donner des pistons mais
voilà exactement c'est si je peux si je
peux justement parce que je sais que
devant la télé les gens ils vont dire il
fait l'apologie écrit rigolé scherwey
moi j'ai décidé de le raconter de façon
humoristique que tu feras spectacle je
fais un spectacle et j'ai préféré
arriver sur scène
de cette façon là en rigolant et tous
tout en envoyant des messages bien sûr
est que parce que si j'étais arrivé on
le fait dans les écoles les collèges les
prisons on va demander si j'arrivais
devant les détenus
et si je le faisais attention c'est pas
beau de volets un volet paul on va faire
la morale à quelqu'un d'autre sur vient
m'aider à remplir le frigo apprend on
parle on écoute beaucoup plus quelqu'un
qui nous fait vite fait et puis surtout
du vrai qui les passionne comme dans un
choc et c'est là tu peux envoyer tes
messages subtilement temps verra les
messages assez sûrs alors on réussit
c'est donc à vous échapper fait et là
vous allez ouvrir alors je j'arrive à
m'échapper déjà je me classe dans un
buisson et je passe c'était 24 9 24
décembre 1980 81 18 la veille de noël et
donc 18h30 je sors de mes nuits sont on
est en plein centre ville
et là je j'attends un petit peu je mets
le long d'un petit mur un couple arrive
vers moi avec une poussette une amie
avec avait une poussette
là je sais pas pourquoi mais c'était eux
il arrive à ma hauteur je regarde le
monsieur jeudi excusez moi monsieur de
vous déranger
j'ai mis un petit frère qui s'est
arraché le thoune douala sur la grille
ma soeur l'emmener aux urgences j'ai pas
de nouvelles ça fait déjà plus de quatre
heures vous pouvez pas m'emmener aux
urgences le mec me regarde il me fait
est ce la serbie et namas 9ème chef
galerie nadar demi arras nos regards
il me disant en arabe qu'il parlait pas
un mot de français qui parlent que
l'arabe je le regarde et je lui dis
didier nadal a en fait il lui a dit tu
laisses moi tenir dans l'automobile
ahmed mois l'hôpital
c'est ça avec vous accueillera problème
si on ne dit pas mais on apprend les
langues essentiellement ça mais ça sert
et donc là ça doit quand même étonnant
essentiellement mois j'apprenais
italienne
et là il me regarde il me dit par contre
serbie les obstacles apple code pénal
il me disait que je monte dans le kop
haskell avec une 4 places il voulait pas
se mettre hors la loi ça c'était très
bien pour toi moi je ça m'arrangeait a
au contraire mais tout en montant dans
le corps je me disais les armes ils
savent se [ __ ] dans la merde quand
même je connais j'ai lu il se rattrape
avec moi dans le coffre il prend au sein
de malfaiteurs le matin le prouve c'est
un amour ce prix là non mais c'est un
amour voilà donc quand je suis monté
dans le coffre on est on arrivé au
quartier
j'ai quitté ces braves gens tout ça j'ai
retrouvé mes potes nemir atm voilà tous
tous mes potes mais là là il y en a on a
récupéré trois voitures on a gagné la
capitale on était à caen dans le
calvados
on est arrivé à paris sans encombre et
l'âge et voilà j'ai bénéficié de l'aide
de plein d'amis tous ensuite j'étais
chez les indiens dans l'arrière-pays
niçois
j'avais une cousine qui vivait comme des
indiens ses meilleurs plans katie sans
téléphone sans rien avec l'au-delà puis
le lait enfin voilà il ya des indiens
wes appelle ça comme ça c'est le corps
ces communautés c'est vrai ils vivent
dans des hippies on les appelle les
indiens non j'ai dit les tipis dans des
tipis dans des films mais qu'en fait
c'est quoi ce délire mais moi ça
m'arrange et donc voilà cela fait donc
j'ai passé un long moment je vois là
j'ai appris j'ai rejoint mes potes au
bout de deux mois j'ai rejoint mes potes
à paris et là j'ai appelé mon petit
frère tout les perquisitions chez moi
chez mes parents chez me d'autant tout
là alors justement la télévision contre
l'évasion de david et donc tu te vois à
la télé ouais je me nomme est pas ma
photo il voyait tout le parc on estime
son truc c'est rachid arhab le
présentateur du jt de 20 heures c'était
donc le jeudi 24 décembre 98 donc il
parle de vous alors que vous êtes à
table en train de regarder la télé
tranquille avec des gens que vous ne
connaissez pas voilà je suis en plein
repas et il ya même le monsieur à côté
de moi des mois je suis en train de
rigoler et on rigole bien
d'un coup le donc vois le truc est le
monsieur me regarde il fait et lui là on
peut lui souhaiter un joyeux noël quand
même ouais bah tu vas pas d'ipad il aura
tout de suite mais non mais là c'était
jeudi bas avaient complètement mdi bomba
d'accord il a voulu cambrioler une
banque mais sans arme et sans violence
non bitumée monsieur j'adhère
complètement cédé nickel tout est donc
là j'appelle mon frère je dis à mon
frère est ce qu ils ont été chez moi ce
que j'avais pris un petit appartement
dans mon coeur près de mon cas car vous
êtes en cavale depuis qu'on a fait deux
mois que suis en cabas moi et mon frère
me dis ils ont été partout frères
cousins cousines ma mère bien évidemment
partout mais on dit chez toi dhabi
disions pas été non je dis bah ça tombe
bien c'est là bas que je vais aller
planquer donc pendant un an vous êtes en
cavale et vous êtes chez vous et je me
mets chez moi non mais c'est non non
mais s'ils viennent jamais il vient pas
je laisse la porte ouverte
moi je me dis si ils viennent autant
qu'il défonce pour la porte et je le
redis je suis parent mais venez voilà et
en même temps ça fou - dans la merde les
gens qui peuvent me cacher parce qu'ils
auraient pris recel de malfaiteur sonne
ne vous a dénoncé non masque en fait
dans le quartier on avait vraiment une
bonne mentalité il y avait la loi de
l'omerta puis surtout le précise un truc
mais il connaissait pas votre adresse
la police mange
moi j'étais ici j'étais domicile et chez
mes parents et il savait pas que j'avais
pris un petit un petit studio il savait
pas et je râle end de cabanes un ans de
cavale
ces normes c'est rien comparé à la suite
pas vrai c'est un cocktail assez alors
mais vous changez vous changer de look
voilà change de louge acheter vous
achetez un faux passeport mais je
combats vous dites n'importe qui peut se
faire une nouvelle identité avec 5000
euros ouais ça c'est enfin c'est minimum
des fois ça à 10000 15000 ça peut être
même 20000 ça dépend de mes
connaissances
mais c'est vrai que chacun moi j'ai
évité j'en ai eu un mais je mangeais pas
voulu m'en servir parce que des fous
voilà c'est bien quand vous êtes resté
chez vous donc pour cette première
évasion vous décidez de vous rendre au
bout d'un an
alors au bout d'un an vous dites car j
brand ne pouviez plus en fait de votre
quotidien
c'est pas vrai j'ai passé mon années de
cavale avait là j'avais ma femme et qui
j'ai grandi dans le quartier depuis ses
sens parlant mais quel homme dit david
on en train tout en train de [ __ ] ta
vie en l'air un joule eu un jour où
l'otite attraperont moi je veux des
enfants avec toi rends toi je dis ouais
mais ça va être long à me dis je vais
attendre
vas-y on paye ses drm sont heureux donc
là le 27 janvier 2000 c'est l'heure du
jugement et j'ai dit c'est là que je me
rende en plein jugement et donc je me
suis rendu et le truc de dingue ça les
haoussas les a énervé parce que j'ai
rendu les menottes en plein jugement ah
ouais là il fit croyais que c'était y
juger les supplications voilà et surtout
je suis arrivé en courant parce que je
voulais pas arriver aux abords du palais
de justice clopin clopant deviens branle
ait attrape j'ai eu si je venais membres
donc j'ai dit à mes potes vivant en
courant mais quand je suis arrivé en
courant ils se sont dit les partis en
courant il revient au courant il revient
que les menottes il se fout de notre
gueule
donc là il était surtout j'étais commune
connue comme le loup blanc
voilà donc le proc demande c'est en un
an pour l'évasion vous est donc quasi
condamné à cinq ans de prison
non en tout en tout je suis condamné a
plu presque dix ans mais avec 20 grâce à
ça avec les grâces et tout conditionnel
bien tenu et où je sors au bout de cinq
ans alors elle femme a attendu pendant 5
et quand vous sortez vous vous dites que
toute cette vie de voyou est enfin finie
voilà moi j'avais j'avais l'idée de ce
spectacle raconter tout ça avec de
l'humour de la dérision et beaucoup de
messages
j'avais tout ce qu'a dit cette idée là
alors vous devenez éboueurs vous avez
repris votre routine
mais vos anciens collègues voilà voyous
ont eu de nouveau besoin de vous ne
pouvez pas refuser
comme ces derniers l'avaient aidé pour
sa cavale bien sûr donc forcément ça
charge renaît donc les bourses plongent
et voilà et vous faites quoi c'est une
deuxième fois comment et pourquoi
et bien mes potes viennent me voir et me
disent david si on t'a aidé c'est à ton
tour mais je dis on va pas refaire les
banques si on re neutralisés à l'âme
comme je lé fais avancer autant laisser
notre carte de visite
ici on va faire un auteur comme on avait
toujours fait le shit à haute échelle
vision va on va faire on va faire dans
le shit on avait des contacts en espagne
au maroc tout embarras origines et on va
ramener du haschich pour voilà pour
remettre tout le monde bien jeu comme ça
je vais payer ma dette envers vous allez
voir que je mon tour je vous aide aussi
les gestes ceux qui sont en prison et
est donc on a installé des go-fast et
tout est au bout d'un certain moment et
j'ai été réglé en à barcelone j'étais
réglable et les voitures se sont fait
attraper sur l'allée donc moi j'ai pas
fait encore attrapée en fait vous n'avez
jamais réussi un coup en fait si si
justement maintenant mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quand tu te fais attraper
pour un coup tu en as fait ça c'est que
tu as dit quelque chose de très
important et qui est bien je trouve
c'est que tous les voleurs pense qu'ils
seront jamais attraper c'est ça mais
comme deux et deux font quatre un jour
ou l'autre fatah bien sûr ses symphonies
c'est ça qu'il arrive ccsp connaît la
trappe et à oui je me fais attraper la
frontière espagnole pour trafic
international de haschisch
là ils mettent en prison donc deux ans
prison deux ans et lors de ton jugement
tu t'es va d'une nouvelle fois comment
tu as fait ben en fait j'avais jamais
réussi j'avais le j'avais réussi à être
libéré juste avant parce qu' il pouvait
pas me tenir plus de 24 mois en mandat
de dépôt
la loi française qui peuvent te voilà il
faut que tu sois jugé donc j'avais été
libérant provisoire j'arrive au jugement
up et là ils mettent cinq ans ferme et
j'avais déjà fait deux ans qu'il restait
trois ans à faire et me disent mais toi
sur le côté avec les policiers le temps
et là bas pareil que foule te fasse beau
jeu la famille attendait avec une moto
je repars moto boum on l a profité d'un
moment de distraction et policiers pour
prendre la fuite voilà gère que la fuite
est là
ou est ce que tu vas tu veux pas
retourner chez toi non non la ggt voir
mes potes je leur ai dit les gars voilà
vous avez vu je dois plus rien lundi
david est un bonhomme c'est donc là j'ai
pris ma femme et ma fille que j'avais
une fille entre temps pendant donc on
est parti à paris et j'avais dans l'idée
de monter ce spectacle et est donc voila
et on a pris un appartement au nom à ma
femme tu décides de reprendre une vie
totalement normal ce que tu prends un
appartement au nom de ta femme voilà et
tu te mets à chercher du travail
voilà parce que je me dis je veux pas
remettre les mains dans le cambouis
enfin voilà j'avais vraiment des idées
honnête j'ai vraiment vécu non envie
d'une vie simple mais une vie simple
mais tu a falsifié le diplôme
d'ambulanciers d'un membre de ta famille
au pouvoir
toi même postulé est toujours en cavale
donc voilà donc tu falsifient le truc et
là tu travailles tout en étant cavalca
une vie normale quand tu vas travailler
tu rentres chez toi le soir et puis là
c'est original parce que je me fait
embaucher dans une société d'ambulances
qui attachés au samu de paris
et je travaille tellement bien que mon
nom mon équipe d'endurance nous là ils
nous ont mis nous met constamment
attaché au samu de paris savait que j'ai
trois ans à faire et je fais des samu
dans tout paris et donc je croise plein
de policiers on peut sabawi move la
route pour aller là des fois même des
fouilles meurt c est lorsque toi tu es
ambulanciers donc tu t'es mêmes faits ou
peut-être ouvrir la route
il en est pour des urgences ils m'ont
verra août des fois ils m'arrêter je
présentais la feuille de s'amuser on va
sur un objet hop j'ai tout appris sur le
tas un autodidacte et il pouvait pas
savoir et je dis un truc tu dis plus
c'est gros plus ça passe
c'est ça en fait nous toute notre
jeunesse on a tout fait au culot quoi
c'était au cas où c'était on en est j'ai
grandi là dedans pour moi c'était banal
c'était on faisait et puis surtout voilà
grg attention faut bien préciser que
j'étais ambulanciers et j'écoutais bien
j'étais avec des collègues étaient super
bon et qui m'ont appris le métier j'ai
tout appris et je vais aux ambulanciers
sont pas d'idées
bizarre lui connaît pas du tout le
métier d'où il sort non j'ai réussi à
les embrouiller j'apprends vite sans
préparation aucune gêne mais c'était
voilà je faisais paf paf fumier temps tu
les embrouiller quoi ouais et puis et
puis et puis j'ai aimé le faire sama ça
m'a plus d'aider les gens de faire ce
que je faisais et tout en montant sur
scène le soir se fait alors justement
c'est ça qui est fou c'est qu' il allait
sur scène incroyable sony ce n'est pas
tant alors qu'il était en cavale
c'est un travail à ameuter un pari non
mais c'est rigolo c'est de la provoc
annonce franchement c'était pas du tout
pourvu que je l'avais si le chien une
cabale c'est pire que spaggiari là mais
ouais non mais là sincèrement c'était
pas dans la provoc cité je monte sur
scène j'avais public jeux racontait
comment je m'étais évadés la première
fois je racontais comment avec du
message et tout ça et les jambes ne
pouvait pas savoir que j'étais en cavale
je jouais sous le nom de palu l'envers
d'arsène lupin humains et donc je ne
disais pas le crime s'est inscrite et
même pour y redire non je peux pas je
suis en cavale je suis parti c'est vrai
qu'on me faisait une blague
il disait en spectacle et en cavale il
avait tout le monde il est beau c'est
une connerie c'est une connerie par
exemple je dirais je suis en cavale vous
dirai et [ __ ]
[Rires]
c'est ça peut nous faire un happening
alors vous avez été arrêtées après ces
quatre ans de cavale
comment ça eh bien mon frère mon petit
femme avait prêté une voiture et
j'allais justement dans les théâtres
tout ça et je me fais contrôler et là je
dis j'ai pas de papiers tous deux m'ont
donc quand même un faux nom comme
d'habitude et toussa toussa pas et bien
policiers fouillé la voiture est dans la
boîte à gants au fond il trouve un
papier que mon nom il tape au terminal
est là et david desclos là ils disent à
dos et il est recherché il braque de
tunisiana non là c'est mon frère je dis
moi depuis tout petit mon petit frère
quand on va au commissaire à mon petit
frère edmond non moi je donne le sien
voilà il dit arrête de nous embrouiller
m'emmène au commissariat ils mettent la
main à la goutte d'or quand il traite la
main à ces voix-là tatou qui ressort et
il voyait ma faute aux médias non je
vous ai dit comme mon frère vue au
commissariat il donné mon nom et ses
abdos
là c'est mon frère avec l'âge les
embrouilles car ils abritent à varzy
mais non mais je disais je les
embrouiller et là ils m'ont dit et là il
ya un policier et je faut que je rende
hommage quand même et me dit david ça
fait vingt-quatre heures que tu nous dis
des conneries tu vas prendre usurpation
d'identité que ça va être pire
écoute tout ce que tu as dit là on
oublie on déchire dit avril et va payer
ta dette et voilà et là je les écoutais
il a été sympa il a déchiré tôt et là
j'ai dit ma vraie identité
je me suis retrouvé à fresnes arrivé à
fresnes devant la juge expliquer tout ce
que j'avais fait elle alors des
recherches c'est ça il raconte tout vous
raconter vous arrivez devant la juge ait
voulu raconter tout ça et je raconte que
j'ai travaillé au samu je faisais des
scènes ouvertes j'avais j'ai écrit une
pièce de théâtre tout ça et là il ya
trop haïti clean clean clean à la et
donc elle décide ce qu'elle est
tellement impressionnée elle décide de
clécy son tir est seulement avec un
bracelet électronique au bout d'un an
quand même j'avais un an de prison elle
aime dit il me restait encore à un peu
plus d'un an à faire
oui hélas elle a été génial et je lui
rends hommage aussi à ses débuts elle me
dit monsieur desclaux votre histoire me
glace me donne des frissons on a fait
des recherches on voit que tout est vrai
vous n'avez rien à faire en prison vous
avez faire quelque chose de bien de
votre vie et moi je fais un effort je
voulais sortir avec le bracelet
électronique et ensuite au bout de
quelques mois vous donnera un
conditionnel donc j'ai fait 6 ou 7 mois
de grâce électronique ensuite j'ai eu la
conditionnelle et là j'ai pu faire tout
j'ai travaillé d'abord dans les
assurances passe quelques brasses
électronique la conditionnelle je
pouvais pas le théâtre
donc j'ai travaillé j'ai tout déchet
sans prétention aucune j'ai vraiment
bien bossé
13 12 jeunes du genre mais elle a été
très intelligente c'est la punition pour
rien elle faisait quoi l'avocate la
voilà une pelle de important c'est pas
une vengeance de la société c'est le
premier pas de la réinsertion qu'on peut
pendant qu elle a fait son travail sept
juges elle n'a pas été indulgente
elle a analysé concrètement des faits
qu'elle a vérifié et elle a pris une
décision souveraine que ce qui est son
diable plutôt si oui bien sûr
s'il a bien fait là bas il ya des ratés
aussi bien sûr mais là elle a bien faire
la preuve pas j'étais classé
multirécidiviste sa classe et mutent
irrécupérables et de faire ce qu'elle a
fait en faisant confiance
elle a eu un grand professionnalisme de
tous et c'est pour ça que maintenant je
dois apporter tous ses messagers et
montrer qu'on m'a pas donné une chance
pour rien parce que voilà ce qui ce qui
a été bon voila j'ai su saisir cette
chance et maintenant je fais tout ce que
je fais aujourd'hui
alors
[Applaudissements]